[Music]
all right let's go to binghamton new
york dominico is there dominico how can
we help
hey hey my fiancee turned me to you guys
just this week on my 23rd birthday oh
wow
happy birthday
yeah what a present
check out these crazy people on
this podcast
you don't sound terribly excited about
it dude do you hate us you can be honest
no i've actually been listening to you
guys very religiously all week listening
to you guys at work everything i just
bought dave's book yesterday total money
makeover i've been reading it every
night
amazing but my fiance and i were talking
last night because we're going over our
bills for the rest of the month and
she got she told me to call and get your
guys opinion because if we can't figure
out what to do um
my car
i
have i have a car payment
sadly
um
and my loan is like 15
762
and i paid 283.25 a month but it's only
kelly blue book valued at 7
972
yeah
so i'm trying for
we were trying to figure out would be
better just for me to get rid of the car
or
keep it or
what to do because we're getting behind
on bills and everything and we're just
trying to get stuff figured out because
we moved into our first apartment
together
just back in june okay
okay how much do you make a year
um
i want to say roughly maybe about
forty thousand forty okay and what other
debt do you have besides the car
just you know your fiance just you
um my credit cards
which i got
a uh
credit card for
for my car to fix it which that's um
that i
use just for an oil change um i've got a
car through walmart and i got it
how much is how much how much total do
you think is in credit card debt
uh about a thousand about a thousand
okay and that's all you have no student
loans yeah
and your student loans awesome okay
so
i think for you i mean kind of our rule
of thumb is if you can't pay off the car
in 18 months
it needs to go
12 to 18 months so if you don't think
you can pay it off in a year that you
can just
you know work you're you know working an
extra job selling stuff doing whatever
you can to throw money at this car
payment well first the credit card i
want you to get rid of that thousand
dollar credit card cut up the credit
cards when we get off the phone if you
haven't already like get rid of those
get a thousand dollars saved up thousand
dollars to your car so you're you have
about two thousand dollars
to get this ball rolling to get your
emergency fund and then to start
attacking this car
um
so if you can't pay it off uh in 12 to
18 months then yeah my my advice would
be to sell it and you'll take you'll
have to take a loan for the difference
um because you won't be able to get as
much you know you're not able to sell
the car and then
make some money off of it obviously
because it's gone down in value so much
um
but to take that loan
um which will be obviously less than
that i mean you'll have eight thousand
dollars
left on that car loan and that's what
you could attack instead of the 15 000
if that's what if that's what you choose
unless you just decide to buckle down
and
attack
the car payments and the car the car
loan
uh in the next year
how much are you making dominica 40. i'm
ex i make 16 an hour but my
yearly income is like around 45.
and what is that job what are you doing
um i work at a fabrication shop yeah
yeah
where would you go
to make extra money if you wanted to
make i mean if you really went hard you
you don't have kids yes or no
no no kids so it's just you two and this
is your debt not
uh you know the two of you is dead so
what would you do could you pick up some
more fabricating work you know around
cars and stuff make some really nice
money per hour if you added another 15
to 30 hours a week
yeah like i've already got a second job
lined up i'm going to be working like
friday saturday nights at a haunted
attraction for the halloween season how
much is that going to pay you
about like 250 a weekend because i'm
only working two days a weekend yeah
well good for you but i would really
look at your other options i mean can
you pick up some extra work you know
messing around on cars or whatever just
to maximize
uh your income right now because this
you could knock this stuff out easily in
nine nine months twelve months if you
really just worked like a maniac this is
not that much money
yeah like i've been
putting applications out for second jobs
anywhere i've been putting applications
at gas stations and all yeah but hold on
a second domenico listen listen man
you're worth way more than that
don't put apple cases in to a gas
station you're you're a skilled
tradesman i mean think about how many
people you know in the car game am i
right or am i wrong am i missing
something
yeah i
yeah i'm completely not looking at the
bigger picture
all right but this is saying i'm not
looking at it no you're not dude you
you're a skilled tradesman i'd be
looking for that kind of work where you
can be making 18 an hour 25 an hour
where the the time is really paying off
not standing there holding a rope and
letting a bunch of idiot teenagers walk
through a haunted house it's just not a
good use of your time we gotta get
serious you have a real skill
yeah yeah what do you think what do you
think about this do you agree with me
i'm okay to be wrong yeah
no i i'm agreeing with you i just i'm
just speechless because i've
never really thought about it like that
i've always
grown up with you get what you can get
and don't feel fit but now that you're
saying it now it's like
well i actually agree with that i agree
but listen get what you can get and the
haunted house ain't get what you can get
that's just get whatever's there
go out there and get some skilled trades
work that you're already qualified for
and you've got all kinds of connections
you're in that game already you're a
fabricator that is a premium physical
trade man uh we're talking about can i
make 500 700 over a weekend let's set
our sites a little bit bigger let's get
a third job because again we're looking
at uh 16
760 dollars that you've got to pay off
and i know you're brand new to this and
i'm so glad you called but i'm going to
tell you something man if you start
seeing yourself as a money-making
machine
you'll go out and do that and we won't
settle for the haunted house thing so
here's a little challenge domenico i
want you to go find some other work and
then call the haunted health people up
and say hey i'm sorry i got something
better
you got a few weeks haunted house people
to fill my spots i'm about to make three
times on what i was gonna make i love
that ken well done deuces i'm out of
here i'm not doing that but to give
people the
you know and again not that working at a
haunted house or gas station no there's
nothing wrong with it no nothing wrong
with that but the fact that you have the
skill and to be able to value yourself
even more in the marketplace and again
you're you've been in this for four days
right just this week so there there is a
level of all this that you're learning
so much so i just want to applaud you on
that of just learning and saying hey
what i'm doing i want to do something
different and now your mind you're
starting to grow in that your mind is
being expanded and so this challenge ken
has given you is wonderful so well done
ken i love i love hearing that and
hearing you demonica be like man okay i
can do this because you can yes dominica
this is for your future bride your
babies i mean you got the chance to wipe
this debt absolutely free in nine months
12 months at the most and your future is
the best
that you could possibly imagine the best
is yet to be young man get after